jaws - is out on blu-ray now and if you
guys saw my friend and I Matt Brando we
reviewed jaws 3d last week and it was
tons of fun and we figured why not fill
in the last gap of the jaws film that I
haven't reviewed leading up to the
shallows finding dory was out whole
bunch of fish movies so hey fish let's
talk about fish how are you doing today
Matt thank you very much for coming on
miss Amaya chief jaws 2 for me isn't
like a disaster like three and four is
it's at least a watchable movie Roy
Scheider returned and again of course
there's a shark terrorizing the beaches
of Amity Island
Charles was such a humongous success it
was one of the biggest movies of all
time first movie to ever make more than
100 million dollars at the box office it
was the first real blockbuster so
obviously there's going to be a sequel
I'm surprised it actually took three
years to make it I think the best route
for this story is to have the town thank
the sharks not really here and then
maybe Brody is paranoid which they
already talked about the earlier script
versions don't show the shark the town
doesn't know
Brody's crazy until Tina's attacked I
think when Tina's attacked with Edie
Edie dies that's when we see the shark
for the first time that would make a
really great idea
they show the shark a lot because you
know I mean obviously everyone who goes
this movie and sees the shark on the
poster you expect a shark yeah but I
think in retrospect it would have been a
more interesting story like you're
saying if there was a little bit more
paranoia because right from the opening
scene you see those two divers get
attacked by a shark so you know it's a
shark and you're on Roy Scheider's side
but it would have been a more
interesting story dramatically if there
was just a shred of doubt maybe even in
the viewers mind even though you're
you're you know you're going to get a
shark yeah but I think maybe for the
characters it would have been better
yeah see the thing is with that first
attack if you just had like an ambiguous
like these divers got attacked we never
show the shark at all and then it's all
in that camera you think that after like
Jaws one after he killed a shark saved
everyone who was doubting him already
they would give him maybe the benefit of
the doubt when he comes around saying I
think something's going on yeah but they
don't everyone's liking
no it's the the beaches it can't close
the beaches and they throw in like some
stupid subplot where his wife's boss has
like all these maybe maybe sort of
feelings for her II think she's the
greatest woman on earth or whatever it's
funny you say that because that you're
smart to pick that up they actually cut
that down a lot I don't know if it's in
the deleted scenes for the blue-ringed
because we haven't watched that yet but
there's a cut little scene that was in
the shooting script like the latest
script for jaws to wear Len like asks
her to dance he goes no and then they
they kind of go off and dance and then
they grab a bottle champagne or wine and
I leave oh yeah there's a lot of like of
that like overtones are like on the nose
about Len Peterson liking Ellen Brody or
Joss
- works for me is Roy Scheider's
performance I think he's the best part
of the movie he classically clashed a
lot with a director it's very well known
that they had some serious arguments
during the making this movie that
actually got physical apparently
according to reports so obviously there
was some difficulty there because when
you watch the movie you can kind of tell
that it's a couple different visions
because originally as you know this
movie was directed by a completely
different person and so the whole movie
kind of got reworks and you can really
feel that kind of strange like Roy
Scheider's on his own little mission and
he's trying to prove things and then all
these kids are constantly playing and
then you're they're trying to give the
kids some characterizations but then the
kids go out and the shark just attacks
them and it kind of becomes a slasher
movie a horror film really where the
first one is more of an adventure thrill
ride with great characters this one was
more like let's just have the shark pop
up and eat some people and we're going
to give it scars it's going to be burnt
that being said there are some things I
like about this movie as I said Roy
Scheider is good in the film they do
actually attempt to give some
characterizations to people unlike Jaws
3 and jaws 4 they actually do try to set
up some characters that you could maybe
get behind even though the whole town
doubting him again is kind of stupid and
it's an obvious thing that that's just
like really come on this this town
should be hurting right now yeah like
three years ago some serious shit happen
in this shark they should give him the
benefit of the doubt
it gives him some more characterization
when they fire him and you kind of get
behind him but then when he goes out to
rescue the kids to try to save his
children and those other kids you don't
really get much of anything in regards
to an arc between him and a town it just
fades out into a sunset when he finds
the
kids and you get that one scene with
Lauren Gary where she's like I don't
like you you in person that walks away
they actually shot this of Larry Vaughan
the mayor when they're doing like a
before and after when they're talking
about Brody and then Brody comes in with
the photograph knees going crazy and
it's a really nice little line where
everyone votes to you know get rid of
Brody as chief like Glen Peterson and
everyone raised their hands but the
mayor doesn't he's like this and then he
goes on uh the mayor I think lends says
like I want to pose and he's like and I
don't think they filmed or at least they
cut right before the line but there's a
line in the script where he said like
the man did a lot for this town or
something like well actually like the
mayor now speaking of characterization
must want want to talk about the kids oh
sure let's get into the kids not just
that it dude she's looking at you see
the way she looked at you that's most of
the movie yeah this type of movie in
regards to characterization for
teenagers has just stuck with movies all
the way until today like you get a whole
bunch of horny kids together and that's
it they're horny and maybe they might
procreate that's the characterization
for this movie the son Mike is awful oh
my god like everything he says like he
has like this overdramatic like no yeah
maybe I'm not sure if he acted again
actually I don't know I have to look
that up the shooting script had just a
little bit more characterization like
when they're liking punching shit in the
beginning with teenagers yeah and I'm
like oh who do you want to take out
tomorrow on a date Oh below you and I
was like this sucks especially compared
to the earlier version made by scheckler
which is probably my favorites jaws
numerical - that one actually had a lot
of great characterization for the kids
actually made me care about the kids
when they're being attacked rather than
the movie I'm just like go shark kill
him I don't yeah really it's just a
bunch of because uh here's an example I
can you
like when they're like boating out like
these two chicks come in they end up
being a Jackie but her name was like
Brooke and something else and then so
Mike end up his motivation the whole
time was this one chick it wasn't like
my friends are boning and I'm painting
oh my god I know he takes his new chick
out to sale and then I'll be all the
other friends and stuff come out to sale
too and one of them is like a boat of
two girls and one of those girls is his
ex and his jealous like all this really
cool characters they show at this time
just to dub down and kind of sucks so it
seems like with this if you watched our
review of jobs 3d it seems like there
were always at least attempts to try to
make the films a little bit better than
they ended up being oh yeah trois twos
not horrible but when you watch it it
really just plays as a horror movie with
a shark and chief Brody has the only
characterization which I bet you he
squeezed out of the directors neck when
they were in the middle of one of these
fights that they had yeah you really
want characterization you read that book
right there the Jon Stewart novelization
right there yeah point to the right
there people you want crazy story that
had so much more depth to what was going
on for the plot that's the Mafia version
right there this town should be dead
like this a huge shark attack economy
should have been crushed that might have
been too dark I agree with the universal
execs but I like reading that thing that
thing's great but that middle one with
the abandoned town and we have to
revitalize it just raises the stakes up
more rather than just this flat sequel
then it I mean I feel like if they did
go that route where they had a town that
was more abandoned that it would have
felt a little bit more not so much
realistic but just there would have been
something be to get behind your there's
really nothing to get behind in this
movie the one thing you can get behind
is chief Brody because everyone's
doubting him and he know that he's that
he's telling the truth
yeah that's the only thing get behind
the characters are so weak
the shark works still mostly for most of
the shots it looks better than the shark
in Jaws 3 that's for sure
when you see a film like Jaws if you
never heard of it before and you pick it
up in it you see a shark go as a shark
movie when you watch jaws you go out
going that was a chief Brody movie that
was a Quint movie that was a Hooper yeah
like that was awesome these characters
are great I want more of that
jaws to at least gave us one of those
characters but they didn't give him a
single interesting thing to do
unfortunately they obviously went
through a lot of
script changes just like jaws 3 I don't
know about 4 but maybe they did they
went through director changes even on
this year I think a studio was
scrambling to discover what they could
do with this humongous property they had
never had anything like that before like
wow all these people love this movie
maybe when too much pressure or
something they probably realize it was a
nominated for Best Picture it basically
launched Steven Spielberg's career and
everyone loved it the critics people the
Academy all of that they were probably
like well we have to make this a money
milking franchise and they did I guess
yeah what everyone else does that this
made the the the horror sequel that you
said that in Jaws 3 this is kind of like
a Jason movie that the shark comes up
it's like not that the music is loud
yeah so the scene where I don't remember
and then you said to me I don't remember
this part is when Tom Andrews was just
diving into the water and you know going
for lobsters or whatever right in the
Sackler script the one that between the
two crazy ones he's actually diving down
he's chasing like this little like fish
he can't find it and goes into the
darkness and then as a shot like the
shark coming out of the darkness with
the fish in its mouth like that's kind
of scary and then the man he goes up
instead of like the thing just brushing
by them like this sucks oh my god we
have to say we have to say it
pretend there's a can of gasoline Oh
oh my god Jesus pours a bunch of fucking
gasoline all over herself and blows up I
mean it was just so poorly done and I
think a lot of it has to do perhaps with
this director not being a very good
director of action because have you ever
seen the movie Supergirl which I've also
done Larry ASSA T of yeah he sucks at
directing action anything like that and
so I don't know what happened there but
that was shit
so in a Sackler script that boat scene
those two boaters was like a couple and
Brody knew them when he interviews the
old lady
he's like Lola asked a bunch of
questions like who were they were they
out of town and she goes no friends and
then ends the scene jaws 2 is a
watchable movie if you've never seen the
jaws films Jarls 1 & 2 you can watch
three is hilariously awful but it's at
least funny and especially if you have
the 3d blu-ray and can watch it in 3d
and that way the film has some kind of
gimmick at least that you can enjoy its
watchable or just fucking stay away that
movie is garbage and ass but I have
reviewed all of them now so if you want
to check out all those reviews you can
now it jaws 2 is a watchable sequel it's
serviceable like you can't take a
masterpiece jaws to ten out of ten
unless your last name is Cameron or
Spielberg follow that up with another
masterpiece and that's one negative
thing I can say about jaws is that when
ends like oh no I want more so you pop
in Jaws two and you're like okay this is
alright yeah but stop after that it's
not quite as good as I remember it being
to be honest yeah it's not quite as good
is for me it's kind of like a BB - level
I don't really know what grade I would
actually give it probably a B - B right
in there but it's just it's just not
quite as great as I remember being when
I was a kid because a kid I was like
jaws do it yeah it's got Roy Scheider so
you mentioned something in the last Jaws
3-d review and if you watch my stuff I
can buy the really expensive shark from
San Diego comic-con 2015 it's like a
hundred dollars it comes with bloody
Quint and a bloody shark with a machete
it's friggin awesome you mentioned that
there was something you were looking for
oh what's that
but right there with this yeah
that way shit me it's that blue box oh
what's inside the little box
I don't know why don't you open the blue
box Matt alright oh shit
which we put in the background I have a
little shock uh-huh mako shark uh-huh
yeah see if we're oh now we got you a
deep blue sea because mako sharks from
deep blue sea that's true you know I
don't really think that's what you
wanted though he's pretty cool though I
don't really think that's what he wanted
I think oh my god
I think um Jesus I think this is
actually what you wanted alright see you
learn maybe hey oh shit
now I apologize the boxes an in pristine
condition but this thing is rare as fuck
and that's the best quality I could find
my god it is gorgeous
people look at this thank you very much
my friend you're welcome buddy um thanks
for being in the videos I feel like
crying
ha ha crazy for what people want some
bonus footage here I saw this because
this is a San Diego comic-con exclusive
as you see a stick right there but they
had him at Toys R Us for a good price of
30 bucks and I literally had like 40 or
50 bucks my bank account I think I call
up you her mother friend I was like hey
this thing's here it's like rare I'm
like I don't know if I wanted like I
don't know and it was gone and I
apologize but I have now made up for
this thank you Chris you are the man
yeah you're welcome man so those the
games back there those jaws games
I mean I'm bored what are you doing uh
nothing we can eat some pizza and play
some games do you want to eat some pizza
and play some games I think we should
okay let's let's go eat some pizza yeah
play something oh and uh get stuck my
eyes
oh yeah this is kind of fun
surprise why is he not like leaving oh
you just jumped off go get him burnsy
Bootsy there goes he so annoying
yeah he's dead
if I say ever has we're gonna cam I want
some people where's Emily oh no where's
Dennis Quaid yeah
it ready for this shift I turn this way
no we were supposed to do always opposed
to kill this to relationship I guess
you've hit job Oh
oh my god that instantaneously killed me
did you see that shit
there's jaws right there's graphics I'm
sorry I'm fucking working there is NES
jaws 1987 NES jobs oh I got killed by a
stinger very fucked you up